[Music]
for months the presidential campaign has
been all about this guy but deep down we
all know we'll look back on 2015 as a
racist spray tan pitstop on a very long
campaign trail there probably won't be a
president Trump but there is one guy who
sang essentially the same things only
he's got a shot of winning he prefers to
protect Christian refugees what I'm
saying is Syrian Muslim refugees should
be resettled in the in the Middle East
in majority Muslim countries he is a
similar immigration plan we will build a
wall that works and I'll get Donald
Trump to pay for and just like Donald
Trump he loves Donald Trump I like
Donald Trump I like and respect Donald
Trump I like Donald Trump he's a friend
of mine Ted Cruz or the count from
Sesame Street is actually diet Trump and
just like the soda the diet version will
still kill you but the big difference is
that Trump only hopes to enact his
retrograde policies whereas Cruz has
already been pushing them in Washington
as a freshman Texas senator he's blocked
more legislation than he's passed he
stopped gun control and immigration
reform threatened to shut down the
government over Planned Parenthood
funding and once filibustered for 21
hours to defund Obamacare oh and on
climate change in the last 15 years
there has been no recorded warming but
he's way too conservative to win the
Republican nomination right well not if
he plays the delegates game which has
been his plan all along see it actually
be the person who gets the nomination
you need over half of the Republican
delegates to represent you at the
Republican convention this July
candidates get delegates support by
doing well in the primaries for most of
the states who hold their primary
elections early you win delegates
proportional to how much of the vote you
get so for example if Cruz wins just 20
percent of the primary vote in his home
state of Texas which has 155 delegates
that still means 31 delegates go to the
convention for him that's more than all
the delegates in Iowa
one two three see most candidates tend
to focus on the early States to build
momentum but Cruz already has campaign
teams in five states that vote after
March 15th in most of those states if
you win the primary you win all the
delegates 120 121 and the thing is other
candidates like Trump and Bush aren't
looking that far ahead yet Cruz even has
a campaign chairman for the US Virgin
Islands who's thought of that but his
long-term calculations don't stop there
he's admitted he's going easy on Trump
and Carson in order to win over their
supporters when they let's be honest
fall out of the race so while Cruz may
be playing the down-home Texan who
sounds like a child actor that's over
memorized his lines if we lose our
freedom here where do we go he knows
exactly what he's doing now if only he
had a foothold in reality
you